tonight is Game seven of the World
Series between the Houston Astros in the
Washington Nationals Game seven rigsy on
tickets I think it's happening right now
yeah yeah I can't wait to find out which
of these two teams ends up turning down
an invitation of the White House that's
gonna be very exciting who will say no
does anybody go there it'd be so great
if it was the Nationals too cuz it's in
town yeah yeah they're like oh we can't
make it it's too far to drive there's a
something blocking the mall here's
interesting story in New York City
low-level offenders can now take an art
class to substitute for jail time yeah
yeah the criminals said no thanks we'll
take the jail time we're good really
yeah I'm with them on that one hey in
Australia nope there's no transition in
Australia those take time and money in
Australia the government wants to use
facial recognition software to track the
identities of people who watch porn yeah
yeah yeah hey Australia I can save you a
lot of money it's men
and now what's used what's the time for
fine the cream we're gonna stop on
everyone who just watches porn